yeah walking to this video playing chess
burger not cheeseburger cheeseburger
from from Brazil and new opponent for
the channel I didn't play in before yeah
let's see benko can't play a player
declined the slider some is interesting
to to test because somehow on many
players take on c4 which is really not a
good line there should be seven SS
better right as various ideas this is
one of them 92 was the move that I i
also have plate in this position if I
was some interesting though it tries to
force um the big point to do something
usually black cam advances to be formed
to check now interesting but now he
impeded stood once yeah well this is
interesting first he tries to I have
this was bad why did that what did I
play this so quickly hmm yeah and I was
irritated a bit because he could have
played a 60m and this could have been
could have been a problem may be okay
but it sits this is possibility it's not
on anymore I'm directly rebooting the
bishop and how I can play if I if this
is in fact interesting they don't want
to take and my my bishop is potentially
misplaced
but he doesn't play it maybe maybe you
will now be 45 yes okay so he will
probably try to play for quick f5 though
this is why i'm playing g3 and Bishop h3
cooking interesting maybe i can i can do
this as well and then Bishop h3 the
right moment I can maybe play Knight to
g5 okay he's quickly allowing this
exchange and now i'm using the square
maybe i can given the time i can advance
like f3 and moves like that okay let's
do that improve the structure and then i
can go maybe night f 1 g 493 ok you can
play h6 but this is not not a big
progress film it just reconsider risk
inside yeah a 5 is not on because of 96
you can try to to to to construct a pawn
check out of this but it's not not
really on ok but I guess the real idea
is after g4 to drop in the night reform
yes Carol probably ok and I cannot go
look to you one is playing age 16
interesting maybe I need I need to drop
spec
I must be cautious taking here and then
be three I could be could be possible
Kim I need him I need to change change
the Colosseum cannot cannot do without
g-form he is really doing that I mean
this is probably not not really working
but it's a it's of course interesting
yeah that's that's not the correct
sacrifice but um its own from a
practical point of view it's certainly
interesting okay
so a 4 let's see you gone ok I'm going
to play that this is may be debatable
and I want to clarify meta cm I can
immediately get rid of the bishop this
is very important and the main thing is
I want the night on d to the night must
play so that after a for a three with a
night on d 2 I can just take I'd be
three yes so should I play a 5mm you
five and 94 yeah come on let's play
let's play actively here maybe it's not
working but I'm on 121 26 yeah well
night night to have six the check is
dangerous at least it's yeah this is
check very big Fork black resigned and
it's even yeah I cannot even play 25
this is check each a stronger check
getting getting a new queen with check
probably made around the corner as well
very complicated stuff but I don't think
it is correct sacrifice
maybe maybe even turn he lost some time
also the computer says it's even i think
this is served tempeh know so i guess
giving me Bishop t to adhere widest
widest better mean I have all my pieces
in play and he cannot easily push a
three he can defend much better of
course this is really helping me
guarantee a white is just winning this
95 to f6 sister is too strong Compeyson
class form so it serve so it's straight
straight win if it does not take on a
form i think the position is about equal
it's very difficult for me to make any
any headway without g4 that was i were
intended to play g4 in turn the future
he can play this move this is
interesting i was retreating to age
three and therefore 96 is not on and try
it again yeah very very complicated
stuff can easily analyze this form for
longer 94 was interesting but probably
ultimately not not enough right thanks
for watching